c'est une image que l'on voit partout
c'est même un souvenir pour les
touristes mais saviez vous que c'est une
des premières publicités françaises car
les petits beurre c'est l'invention du
marketing en 1846 l'entreprise lefèvre
utile autrement dit lui voit le jour une
petite biscuiterie au centre ville de
nantes
quelques années plus tard louis lefèvre
utile reprend l'entreprise de ses
parents
ce génie du marketing va tout
révolutionner près tous nantais avait
compris l'importance de la publicité et
des gadgets dans les affaires affiche
boîte dessins viennent forger l'identité
visuelle de la marque
les stars de l'époque participent à ce
coup de pub l'arrière petit fils lefèvre
utile témoigner en 1995
on a fait appel à des artistes très
connus comme le chat qui était un tuk
aux slovaques qui qui travaillait pour
les affiches de sarah bernhardt et
cetera alors également s'est rapproché
dans d'autres artistes moins connus mais
des artistes de locaux beaucoup de
créations
image
le coup de maître rendre le petit beurre
people grâce à la star du moment où
monstre sacré sarah bernhardt comédienne
internationalement connu et avec une
toute petite phrase elle fera exploser
les ventes des petits beurre je ne
trouve rien de meilleur
car petit but à 6 2 petit nuage sarah
bernhardt alors que la biscuiterie
familiale se transforme en usine les
objets dérivés prennent de l'importance
public visé les enfants mission les
séduire avec des boîtes originales
une première c'est là donc la première
boîte jouets qui a été diffusée par un
industriel de l'agroalimentaire au début
du siècle il a l'idée de faire ses
boîtes en 1894
c'est un ferblantier de nantes qui
s'appelle firmin colas qui va déposer
créer cette boîte
aujourd'hui l'entreprise n'a plus rien
de la biscuiterie familial après avoir
été racheté par le groupe danone la
marque appartient désormais à une
multinationale américaine
mais grâce à tout le marketing des
années 1900 la marque a toujours l'image
d'une biscuiterie nantaise et la
nostalgie fonctionne tellement bien que
les collectionneurs s'arrachent ses
produits de réclame
[Musique]